what is the radius of the circle in the  X Y plane determined by the equation 2x  squared minus 6X plus 2y squared plus 2y  is equal to 45.  to work this out we'll convert the  equation into standard form we have  coefficients of 2 on x squared and Y  squared so we'll divide the entire  equation by 2.  now we need to complete the square so we  have a negative 3x so we need to add the  square of 3 over 2 which is equal to 9  over 4 then we have a coefficient of one  y so we need to add the square of one  over two which is equal to one over four  we add these terms to both sides of the  equation and then we can factor to get  the equation in standard form the right  hand side is 90 over 4 plus 9 over 4  plus 1 over 4 that's equal to 100 over 4  which is equal to 25 which is equal to 5  squared so the answer is the radius is  equal to 5.